it was a really emotional yet powerful
celebration of life for naomi judd
during a public memorial service on
sunday at the mother church of country
music nashville's
ryman auditorium thank you the
star-studded tribute special included
performances and really heartfelt
speeches from the judd family ashley
mcbride bono morgan freeman oprah and so
many more and the ceremony began with
naomi's daughter ashley delivering an
emotional eulogy tracing back to her
mom's humble beginnings in kentucky to
her superstar status
since the 30th of april we have been
remembering the complex and dynamic life
of our mother and story she was every
woman perhaps this is why everyone felt
they knew her she was a nurse she was a
single mom who sometimes relied on
public assistance she was traumatized by
early childhood sexual abuse intimate
partner violence and rape and she was
fired by a boss when she refused to go
away with him for a weekend
she was mamaw to her grandchildren
elijah and grace and to my chosen family
and she was totally extraordinary
the five-time grammy award winner the
multi-platinum artist the hall of famer
who was lauded by millions we are here
tonight remembering an icon and a legend
who left country music better than she
found it
i don't know i mean it's i just think
it's incredibly brave that the family is
able to
um
like they know that she was such a
public person and so loved that they
could do this i can't imagine losing
your mom but then also losing someone
who was so important to
right to people you know especially to
country music and you know to have made
such a difference you know even for
female country music musicians yeah like
it's i i can't imagine dealing with that
as like an added weight of you know you
have to perform your mom yeah she's
having to perform
so um wynonna judd also delivered a
really stunning performance of the rose
alongside brandy carl and spoke publicly
about her mother's passing for the first
time
[Music]
[Music]
is
[Applause]
[Music]
i can't put into words how
devastated i am
it's the first place i've been publicly
i said goodbye to her two weeks ago and
kissed her on the forehead
i know i know i know you do
her eyebrows were still perfect
she was unlike anyone in our family
[Music]
and i miss her so
much
but i will continue to sing i said i
would and
i can't imagine
it's a light of mine i'm gonna let it
shine
not sure where or when but it's gonna
shine
okay
winona also made the powerful
announcement that the jed's previously
scheduled final tour will still continue
because that's what naomi would have
wanted
i'm gonna
have to honor her
and do this to her i'm just gonna have
to
because
that's what you would want
i say
and the show must go on
as hard as it may be
and we will show up together
[Music]
and you will carry me as you carried me
for 38 years once again because
i honestly didn't think i could do it
i mean losing a parent and then having
to
i mean i think it's a you know in a way
um and winona said it there it's like
she knows that her mom would have wanted
to continue oh my gosh i'm a mess my
eyelashes are coming off people geez
louise um you know she knows that her
mom would want to want to continue the
tour and you know as we were talking
about just in that clip i think
sometimes it's a way of um expressing
your emotion to sing and to sing those
songs and you know to feel your mom
again there with you on tour so um you
know i i i'm happy that they're
continuing if that's something that is
you know going to be fulfilling for
winona
and not too hard but i think the fans
will also really appreciate it
and i think they will be emotional
um
you know concerts and and shows and
performances yeah it's amazing to see
how many people
were actually really close with her you
know you've got the oprah's and so many
people and you go oh really oh really
and so it's it's interesting that her
her reach is just so was so far yeah and
probably will continue to be for quite
some time absolutely yeah